we are here with tasha adams ahead of
hosting the mtv movie and tv awards
unscripted girl how is this moment for
you are you kidding it's very surreal
but i am so excited to be here
i mean we've been together on the
journey as they say um from the very
beginning since the start
so you you went from being on reality tv
to hosting the bachelorette now here now
we haven't seen you in a couple months
since bachelorette hosting stuff stopped
what have you been up to fill us in i
mean
i feel like it's been kind of crazy last
year so i was really just doing my own
thing coming back to my center moved to
new york got a new place really been
living my best life traveling doing the
most but now it's time to work in the
dating department are you single are you
dating are there potential suitors in
the crowd here
i mean i may have picked certain people
to be here so that way i can possibly
say hello um just kidding do we have a
reality tv crush i mean
yeah yeah drop a name i mean i know what
you're trying to do here i'm just sick
i'm stirring the pot
we're at the reality tv you might just
have to watch because i might you know
take a little slide
so we just found out miss becca kufrin
engaged so many congrats honestly the
fact that she proposed to thomas is
probably the cutest thing but also
becca just does her own she did the damn
thing she does her own and they're the
cutest couple i'm so excited for them
would you ever date anyone from the
bachelor franchise again
i think i'm good
respectfully respectfully i think i'm
good i think i'm good um well paradise
starts filming in two weeks and becca
met her guy there could we ever see you
on the shores of paradise again you know
i think that's the million dollar
question and uh
you know i'm really looking at the
beaches of like more like cabo these
days salute is cool but i think i'm done
with that little upgrade yeah so we are
here i'm seeing the names of some of our
reality teas reality tv stars um what
can you tease for us what can we expect
on the big night well
every single reality star
is basically here at least the ones we
all love and um the ones that start the
most drama but the real house is the
beverly hills we have selling sunset we
have summer house we have we have
everyone by the way i'm seeing i'm
seeing how you guys are spun a little
reality because some of the beverly
hills women who are put together i'm
there will be drama brewing at these
tables let me tell you i spared no
expense with the detail the seating
chart miss sutton will appreciate i did
some work i did some work i may have
stirred the pot just a little bit we
gotta stir the pot a little bit it's the
reality awards um bethenny frankel
getting the award of the night reality
royalty yeah i mean she is though she's
an absolute icon mogul philanthropist i
mean she's made the most out of her
entire journey and we're so excited to
honor her
so you are hosting this is a big show
have you gotten any advice on awards
show hosting from anyone how are you
heading into it
[Music]
no
no advice but really i was here last
year and so that was the first mtv
movie and tv awards unscripted so it was
really cool to see nikki glazer do that
um and now i'm just really excited to do
it and make it my own i think it's gonna
be so fun we always ask awards show
hosts this how many outfit changes can
we expect
i literally ask for as many as i can
have
they said as many as you want and so
honey six seven eight nine ten whatever
we need okay just do the most one for
every reality star basically
so we know you know your drama we can
expect drama tonight but i have to catch
up with you we're going to do a little
reality rapid fire with tasha adams okay
all right first of all
what was your reaction to jesse palmer
being hired we haven't gotten that yet
okay well i was excited for him i mean
jesse's such a sweetheart but i feel
like
i'm excited for him i think he's gonna
do a good job okay would you ever come
back again is the door open there oh
like with housing
i mean yeah we'll talk about it we'll
see what happens i mean i feel like i'm
doing pretty well doing some other
things so i'm excited to be here do you
want to give people like give us a
straight up tease for the night like
what they can expect how wild it's gonna
get yeah um
basically i might be a matchmaker i
might even stir the pot a little bit and
try to
set up somebody with somebody else or i
might just try to hit on some people on
my own tonight is gonna be an insane
night okay so for the record this is
singleta hosting yes tasha hoster
well i love how you wanted to confirm
that singleta is hosting and uh we're
ready okay i gotta say you do though
have a dynamic duo partner with you
vanessa hutchins is hosting the other
arm of the night how cool does that feel
to be doing this together have you guys
chatted at all i mean we have not yet
but i will see her in any minute
actually um but vanessa's amazing and
honestly she has done this before she's
done the music awards back in 2019 i
think it was so she's been a really good
person to kind of like watch and see how
she runs the waters and i'm excited to
make her proud